he's back the same yet different and you
know I gotta talk about it deep breath
the premiere episode for Peter Capaldi
as the twelfth doctor though I suppose
if we're being technical he's the
thirteenth doctor or really the
fourteenth of you consider that ten kept
the same face to regeneration but you
know I forget all that we'll call him
the twelfth his premiere episode what do
I think honestly pretty happy not blown
away but it worked for me started out
very fun I mean you can't go wrong when
the opening shot is a dinosaur that's
way bigger than it should be in front of
victorian-era Big Ben I mean good that's
a winner of a start they'll try and
restrict any specifics that I bring up
to save stuff that's within the first
half hour if I talk about anything after
that it'll be in in vaguer terms might
as well start with the elephant in the
room Peter Capaldi what did I think
honestly it took me a little time to
warm to him he was a he was a little
shouty at the front end for my taste but
as he went along as he sort of got a
better sense of himself as the episode
progressed I was found myself warming
more to him by the end I'm I'm pretty
much there I didn't quite have that yes
100% that's the dr. moment that I had
with Matt Smith right you know at the
end when he came through Justin the
bowtie hello I'm the doctor you know
that moment I was yes you are I didn't
quite have that moment with Peter
Capaldi yet but I am watching this going
yeah cool it's working and what I really
like that they're kind of bringing to
him right now is true unpredictability
this really feels like a whole new set
of rules for the doctor he's capable of
things that he just wouldn't have done
before I think we even see that flat out
in a couple instances which I'm not
gonna spoil for people but there were a
couple things that he did the actual
action that he took her just the way
that he sort of reacted to what was
going on reacted to his own actions this
is a new doctor with a new perspective
and that's made pretty clear and there's
a fantastically played piece of
ambiguity as far as something that goes
on towards the end so short version
I'm liking him he's fun I'm hoping now
that we've kind of gotten over the hump
and by the end of this episode he's you
know he's got his own outfit he's all
kind of pulled together that next
episode I'll really start honing in on
his frequency cuz there's nothing wrong
with what he's doing I'm diggin all
these choices and I'm diggin the way
he's being written I just feel like I'm
not quite on the same page as him yet I
think I'm gonna get there soon though
what about everything else well some of
the other characters involved Clara I've
had issues with her in the past I still
kind of issues I think the thing is she
just doesn't seem to cope particularly
well early on with the doctor going
through his regeneration and we've seen
that before which is the first reason
it's a little bit annoying but the other
thing is she knows way more about him
than companions usually do because she's
been in his time stream and she had seen
all these different phases of him she
has a much better grasp of what it means
for him to regenerate or she should have
it seems too difficult for me I'm not
saying it should have been a piece of
cake she was just gonna roll with it the
whole time but it seems like she
questions it too much too frequently
given what she knows about him and about
this process we get vastra Jenny and
Strax back they're all in fine form
they're starting to be used a little bit
like utility players which I'm not
loving they add some nice elements and
moments to this episode but the episode
doesn't really require them and it just
makes me a little bit concerned as far
as them possibly starting to get
overused I don't think it's happened yet
but I'm afraid it might as for the main
thrust of the plot it's fine
again it's not exceptional doesn't blow
me away but then again first stories
after a regeneration aren't really about
the story that's being told it's about
how well does that story enable this new
version of the doctor to be shown off of
it because really a lot of the first
stories post regeneration that they can
be a little why here they can just be
bland they tend to not be particularly
exceptional episodes because really
their point is to show off the new
doctor which this does fairly well I
think patting it out too as long as they
did it felt a little artificial I think
in a way they just kind of did that
because dave the doctor was longer than
a standard episode time of the doctor
was longer than a standard episode and
they just felt any well let's just make
this one longer I'm not sure that was
really a reason to do that as far as the
story goes I mean that said I did like
the story I like the villains involved
and there's kind of a little bit of a
callback in there that I think is
distant enough from what was done before
but it's still strong enough linked to
the past that it's cool for people who
have seen that previous stuff which
actually brings up another thing it's
worth just pointing out that this is not
as good at jumping on point for new
people as the 11th hour was the 11th
hour which was Matt Smith's first
episode was really a great place for new
people to jump on you didn't need to
know an exceptional amount about what
had gone on before to really just sort
of go with what was happening I'm not
sure that's really the case here between
recurring characters and callbacks in
terms of the story and references made
by Clara made by the doctor this is not
as clean a break as Tennant to Smith was
and that's not necessarily criticism of
the episode itself I wouldn't call that
a weakness but I know a lot of people
who were trying to get their friends
into the show and I thought oh I'll just
have them jump on with this new episode
new doctor a great place to jump on I'm
not sure that's really been the case
here there's a bit that was at the very
end they just sort of left me scratching
my head slightly I have a feeling that
that's our first drop for whatever the
season long thread is gonna be but this
felt more like wedding my appetite for
more rather than really something that I
could dig into properly
it sounds like I'm being a little bit
critical and maybe I am being a little
bit nit picky but I am very excited for
where things go from here where we
actually started was solid but not
exceptional but did you catch the latest
episode of Doctor Who what did you think
about it how do you think Peter Capaldi
stacked up can you figure out where he
ranks for you in terms of doctors yet or
do you feel you need another episode or
two whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned